- Hello, good afternoon.
Thank you so much for
joining us this afternoon,
and welcome to the Spring
2016 Chubbs Fellowship Lecture
with our esteemed guest,
the Honorable Norman Y. Mineta.
For those of you who don't know me,
my name is Mary Lui.
I'm a professor
in the departments of
American Studies and History,
and the current head of
Timothy Dwight College.
As the Master of the college,
I have the honor of
serving as the custodian
of the illustrious Chubb Fellowship,
established in 1941,
out of a prior large donation
for education purposes,
made in 1936 by Hendon Chubb,
from the class of 1895.
Since establishment in 1941,
the Chubb Fund has been used
for the encouragement and aid of students
interested in government
and American public affairs.
The fellowship initially aimed to foster
an interest in public service,
in local and State affairs,
and then grew over the years
to include numerous distinguished visitors
in national and international affairs,
as well as leaders in the world
of the arts and humanities,
from Wynton Marsalis, Nobel
laureate Aung San Suu Kyi,
and together, these
incredible Chubb leaders
have inspired generations of Yale students
to undertake public services
and pursue leadership roles
in the hopes of creating
a better world today,
and for posterity.
Now with this quick description
of the history and aims
of the Chubb Fellowship,
I'm now delighted to introduce
our current Chubb Fellow,
the Honorable Norman Y. Mineta.
His long and illustrious career
embodies all of the original
aims of the Chubb Fellowship,
to recognize the importance
of local and State leadership,
and also exemplifies the ways
in which the Chubb Fellowship,
in these last few decades,
has expanded to bring in
important national and world leaders,
to inspire our students on this campus.
His career, spanning
50 years, and counting,
'cause it's not over yet,
(audience laughing)
certainly hits all of these notes,
and many, many more.
Norman Yoshio Mineta was
born in San Jose, California,
on November 12th, 1931.
Following the bombing of Pearl Harbor
on December 7th, 1941,
and the signing of Executive Order 9066
on February 19th, 1942,
just exactly 73 years ago this Friday,
the Minetas,
along with more than
120,000 Japanese-Americans
on the west coast,
were forced from their
homes and communities,
and relocated into camps
operated by the newly established
War Relocation Authority.
The Minetas along with
their friends and neighbors,
ended up at Santa Anita Racetrack,
and then moved onto Heart
Mountain in Wyoming.
In 1943, his father received WRA clearance
to leave to teach Japanese language
in the military training facility
connected to Northwestern
University in Evanston, Illinois,
just north of Chicago.
The family would eventually
be allowed to join him,
and Norman Mineta would
spend his middle school years
attending school in Evanston.
So maybe we can claim
you as a Midwesterner.
Following the war,
the Minetas joined many west
coast Japanese-Americans
and returned home to rebuild their lives.
Norman Mineta continued his education,
graduating from San Jose High School,
and the University of
California at Berkeley,
where he participated
in the reserve officers training program.
He served as an Intelligence
Officer with the US Army
during the 1950s,
before joining his
father's insurance business
back in San Jose.
Norman Mineta's path to public service
began with his involvement
in the local Japanese-American
community in San Jose.
In 1962 he was appointed to the San Jose
Human Relations Commission,
and then to the Municipal
Housing Authority Board in 1966.
He then served on the
San Jose City Council.
In 1971 he was elected Mayor of San Jose,
becoming the first Asian
American to hold this office
in a major American city.
In 1974 he was elected to the
US House of Representatives
for California's 13th District.
His service to this district
lasted for 21 years,
where he either sponsored
or co-sponsored 479 bills,
including the Americans with
Disabilities Act of 1991,
and the Intermodal Transportation
Efficiency Act of 1991.
He also played a crucial leadership role
in the landmark passage of the
Civil Liberties Act of 1988,
working closely with Japanese-American
and Asian American community advocates,
and civil rights activists,
and lobbying fellow Congressmen
to redress the unjust
incarceration of Japanese-Americans
during World War II.
In 1994, he co-founded
the Congressional Asian
Pacific American Caucus,
and served as the first Chair.
And after stepping down
from his Congressional seat,
he took a brief vacation
from public service.
No, he didn't (laughing), not really.
He assumed the position of Vice President
of Lockheed Martin Corporation,
and became the Chairman
of the Nation Civil
Aviation Review Commission.
During the second presidential term
of President William J. Clinton,
Norman Mineta was called
back into public service
as a member of his Cabinet,
serving as the Secretary of Commerce.
This appointment made him
the first Asian American
to serve on a Presidential Cabinet.
And under George W. Bush,
Norman Mineta became the
Secretary of Transportation,
and oversaw the grounding
of airplanes in US airspace,
shortly after the third
plane attack on the Pentagon.
Under his term,
he began the creation
of the Transportation Security
Administration, or TSA,
before it's relocation
to the Department of
Homeland Security in 2003.
If any of you have spent
time in the San Jose area,
probably more familiar to
all of you as Silicon Valley,
you can see, still, very much,
how much his service
continues to be celebrated.
You've probably landed
in Norman Y. Mineta International Airport.
You may have driven on
California State Highway 85,
also named after Norman Y. Mineta.
As students who are from San Jose tell me,
you really cannot walk
around and not notice
Norman Y. Minetta's name (chuckling),
on just about everything.
In addition, San Jose State University
built the Norman Mineta
Transportation Institute,
that supports design
and policy innovations
and sustainability and governance,
for local and national
transportation infrastructures.
He stepped down from his
Cabinet position in 2006,
and was awarded the
Presidential Medal of Freedom
by President George W. Bush.
In 2007, he received the
Grand Order of the Rising Sun,
by the government of Japan.
And in 2012, he received the
distinguished Medal of Honor
for Lifetime Achievement
and Public Service,
from the Japanese-American
National Museum.
And now it is my extreme honor
and pleasure and privilege,
that he has accepted the
Chubb Fellowship in 2016.
So please join me in welcoming
the Honorable Norman Y. Mineta
to the stage (applauding).
(audience applauding)
- Mary, thank you very
(throat clearing) very much
for that warm and generous introduction.
And thanks to all of you
for the very warm welcome,
despite the weather as it is outside.
You cannot imagine how thrilled I am
to be honored as the Chubb
Fellow here at Yale University
and Timothy Dwight College.
When I was at San Jose
High School graduating,
my best friend came
here to Yale University,
and I went to Berkeley.
And pretty soon he wrote to me and said,
"Well, I'm here at
Timothy Dwight College."
I wrote back to him, I said,
"Bruce, I thought you were at Yale."
(audience laughing)
Little did I know about the
residential college program.
And yet, about three
years ago, a number of us,
having lived at a certain
dormitory at Berkeley,
decided that we wanted to take it over
in a public/private partnership,
and create a residential college program.
So we raised some $47 million,
and last year we were able
to get a 75 year lease
from the University of California,
and we are patterning the reconstruction
and operation of Bowles Hall at Berkeley
after the residential college program
of the Ivy League schools.
We found a lot of resistance
when were were doing this,
until Nicholas Dirks from
Columbia University, the Provost,
became the Chancellor at Berkeley.
And when we took the idea to him,
he immediately took to the idea
of creating a residential college program.
And so this September,
we will be opening up
Bowles Hall as a RSP,
patterned after the
residential college program
of the Ivy League schools.
And Chancellor Dirks has also indicated
that he's gonna be tearing
down the 11 dormitories
that we have at Berkeley.
He says they look like
Soviet-style stalag creations.
So he wants to take those down
and build them on a
residential college program.
But I am really thrilled,
because Bruce was my closest friend,
and unfortunately passed
away earlier this year.
Was a resident here at
Timothy Dwight College.
Then after graduating
and serving in the Navy,
he came back and graduated
from the School of Law
here at Yale.
But in any event, I am
just thrilled to be here
as the Chubbs Fellow for 2016.
First of all I'd like to
introduce my wife, Deni,
who's here in front.
Honey, you wanna say hi?
(audience applauding)
If you don't mind,
I am going to use a lot
of this presentation
as a personal experience
that I encountered,
even though this has been the experience
of many, many people of Japanese ancestry.
My parents both immigrated from Japan.
My dad in 1902 as a 14-year-older
came to the United States on his own.
And I always think,
would I ever have let my 14-year-old sons
go off to a country where
they don't know the language,
they don't know anybody,
and just started life anew.
But my dad was the number two son.
Everything goes to number one.
So he figured, I might as
well go and see what it's like
in the United States.
And as he said, he didn't know
that much about US geography.
Instead of getting of of
the ship in San Francisco,
he got off the ship in Seattle.
So he was 800, 900 miles
away from where he should be.
But he worked from one lumber camp,
from a farm camp, to
another (throat clearing),
to make his way all the
way down to Salinas,
where his uncle had started to work
for Spreckels Sugar Company (coughing).
I'm sorry, but I'm
just on the tail end of a cold (coughing).
So you'll have to excuse me
if my voice gives out
every so often (coughing).
And I'm more sympathetic
to the person who's handing
the audio back here,
listening to my coughing
through the mike (coughing).
(audience laughing)
So his uncle said, when he got to Salinas,
"You've got to learn English."
So he put him in the first grade.
And he said it was the
most humiliating thing
he has ever done (coughing).
Not because he didn't know English,
but he was five foot two.
And the kids in that grammar school
were getting up as tall as he was.
So he said that became
a very great incentive
for him to learn English (coughing).
By the end of the second grade,
he had decided he had
learned enough English,
so he graduated himself
from the second grade.
And then Spreckels Sugar gave him a job.
So he was very thankful
for that (coughing).
My mother came in 1914,
and she was a picture bride.
'Cause when my dad turned
24 he wrote to a friend,
and said, "You know, it's
time for me to get married,
"but there are no Japanese women here."
So the friend wrote, sent
him a bunch of pictures,
and said, you know, here's
Mary, Suzie, Joanne (coughing).
And he said, "I'm also..."
(coughing)
Excuse me.
"Enclosing a picture of my sister.
"Remember when we used to
tease her and kick her around
"when we were growing up."
So my dad decided to marry his sister.
But he hadn't seen her
for a number of years.
So she was known as part of that group,
known as picture brides.
And they got married in
San Francisco in 1914.
(coughing)
I know this is tougher on you than me,
and I apologize.
So let's fast forward to December 7, 1941.
Now, as Mary indicated,
I was born on November 12, 1931,
and I chose very carefully the
family that I was born into.
A great mother, a great father,
three great older sisters,
and a great older brother,
and I was the youngest of five,
and could not have had a better upbringing
than in that family.
But when December 7th occurred,
and my dad was in the insurance business
and well known in the Japanese community,
and because he knew English,
he sort of became the liaison
between the Japanese community
and the majority community
in San Jose.
And so, we had just
returned home from church,
past noon, on that Sunday,
turned on the radio,
then heard all the news about
what was happening in Hawaii.
And people started calling the house,
wondering, given what's
happening in Hawaii,
what's the impact going to be on us.
And then about 1:30, two o'clock,
Joyce Hirano, our next door neighbor,
comes running in through
the back door yelling,
"The police are taking Papa away,
"the police are taking Papa away!"
So my dad runs out the
front door, next door,
and by the time he got there,
Mr. Hirano was already gone.
He had no idea, and Mrs.
Hirano, nor their son Irving,
knew who came to the house.
But Mr. Hirano was gone.
So my dad came home
and he called the city manager of San Jose
to ask what was going on.
Mr. Goodwin says,
"I have no idea what
you're talking about."
So he said, "But why don't
you call Chief Black."
So he called Chief of
Police Black, and said,
"What's going on?"
And Chief Black said,
"I don't know anything about
what you're talking about.
"Why don't you talk to Sheriff Emig."
So he talked to Sheriff Emig,
and Sheriff Emig said,
"Well, it's not my operation,
"but I do know about it.
"It's the FBI conducting this operation.
"And I'll have the FBI give you a call."
So about 4:30 that afternoon,
the FBI, the special agent in
charge of the San Jose office
came to the house.
And he explained that they
were picking up people
who were sympathetic to the Japanese,
and who were also community leaders.
Well, my dad sot of though,
I'm a community leader.
Why am I not being picked up?
And so he was a little insulted
that he was not being looked at
as a potential person to be picked up.
And, in fact, after the FBI agent left,
my mother and dad packed a suitcase
just in case they came back,
which fortunately they did not.
So, because of all this
transpiring at Pearl Harbor,
people were really concerned
about what was going to happen to them.
And on the west coast at that time,
there was a Western Civil Defense Command
that was headed up by a General DeWitt.
And so, on February 19th, 1942,
President Roosevelt signed
Executive Order 9066,
delegating to the Commanding General
of Western Civil Defense Command,
the ability to evacuate persons.
Didn't say Germans, didn't say Japanese,
didn't say Italian;
just said persons.
General DeWitt never did like
those of Japanese ancestry,
and he used the phrase one time,
once a J-A-P, always a J-A-P.
And he figured if the
Japanese were going to be able
to attack Pearl Harbor,
they would be able to
attack the west coast.
And if they attack the west coast,
what do I do with the 120,000
people of Japanese ancestry
from Washington, Oregon, and California?
And so, with Executive
Order 9066 (coughing)
now in his hand,
he then commandeered race
tracks and county fairgrounds,
because they had build in living quarters,
namely horse stables.
And so (coughing) a number of fairgrounds,
in Washington, Oregon, and California,
including (coughing)
race tracks (coughing),
were taken over by the
Western Civil Defense Command.
And in order to notify us
that we were going to be
subject to evaluation,
they had these big placards,
and they posted them on
the side of buildings,
utility poles.
Attention, all those of Japanese ancestry,
alien and non-alien.
And as a 10-year-old
kid as I looked at that,
I'm going, alien an non-alien.
Who's the non-alien?
So I asked my brother, I said,
"Who's a non-alien."
He said, "That's you, a citizen."
I said, "Well why aren't
they calling us citizens
"instead of non-aliens?"
But already the psychological warfare
was being played on us.
And that's why, to this day,
I cherish the word citizen,
because my own government
wasn't willing to use it on us,
and we were considered
non-aliens (throat clearing).
And then in April of 1942, my brother,
and he was then a sophomore
at San Jose State College,
and he and I shared a
bedroom, and he's crying.
I say, "Al, what's the matter?"
He says, "Well, this is my draft card, 1A,
"fit and able to serve.
"But I got a new one yesterday,
"and it says 4C.
"So I just called the Draft Board today
"to find out what's a 4C.
"Enemy alien."
So here's kid who was
born and raised, San Jose,
who all of a sudden,
as were all Japanese-American
males of draft age,
reclassified as enemy aliens.
So, with all this kinda
confusion and turmoil going,
and anxiety going on in the community,
everyone was having to get rid
of their personal and real properties,
because you could only take
to camp what you could carry.
And as I was saying to a
group of students earlier,
the toughest job I had
was to part with my dog.
And I loved peanut butter,
so my dog's name was Skippy.
(audience laughing)
And a little terrier.
But I had to get rid of him,
and it was the toughest
thing, I think, I've done,
the least for a 10-year-old
it was a tough thing to do.
So we could only pack to take
to camp what we could carry.
Now, my mother, as an example,
always had a fetish about ironing things,
whether it's sheets or anything else.
But she couldn't take her iron,
'cause that was a contraband article.
AM radios, and all cameras,
were contraband articles.
So we were only able to take
to camp what we could carry.
So on the day that we
were leaving San Jose
to board the trains to go
off to camp, May 29th, 1942,
we were boarding the
train at the freight yard;
not at the passenger depot,
but at the freight yard.
But for me, that wasn't too bad,
because the freight yard
was five blocks from my grammar school,
and were were gonna leave at one o'clock,
and a lot of the kids,
during the lunch hour,
came down to the train
to see their friends off.
So, to that extent, it was a plus.
So we boarded the train,
and I was wearing a Cub Scout uniform,
carrying a baseball,
baseball glove, and a bat.
And as I was getting on the train,
the MPs confiscated the bat,
on the basis it could be
used as a lethal weapon.
So I went running, crying, to my dad.
And he said, "No, no,
that's alright, don't worry.
"We'll get a replacement for that bat."
Well we never did,
because there were no stores
in Santa Anita at the camp.
So it was a long time before
I got my own bat back again.
Now, because of this experience...
Now, unfortunately when
we got to Santa Anita,
we were one of the last
groups coming in to camp.
So by that time, all
the stables were filled.
But I used to go visit my
friends in June and July,
and you could just imagine what it's like
in Southern California,
with that heat beating
down on those stables.
And I don't know how those
folks lived in those stables,
given the stench.
But in any event, we were fortunate enough
to be able to be assigned to
one of the barracks buildings
that had been built in the parking lot.
So we were there until, roughly,
the end of November of 1942.
And in the meantime,
they were building these more,
quote, permanent, unquote, camps,
in Arizona, Colorado, Arkansas,
Wyoming, Idaho, and Utah.
And so the camp we went
to from Santa Anita,
was Heart Mountain, Wyoming,
which is about 20 miles
east of Cody, Wyoming,
which all of you know
is about 50 miles east
of Yellowstone National Park.
So we were up there in that
northwest part of Wyoming.
And the day we got there,
the wind was blowing
and all of us from California were just,
couldn't get over how cold it was.
Not only cold, but with that wind blowing,
and that sand just
beating against your face,
it just was something else.
And so we get to our barracks building,
and it's just filled with silt,
and no brooms or anything to use.
So we had to us whatever we could find
to use as a shovel to sift,
or get this sand off to the side.
And schools hadn't been built yet.
And the elders were wondering,
gee, what do we do with the kids?
So they had written to the Boy Scouts
and the Girl Scouts of America, said,
"Please come to the camps
"and organize troops for us,"
which they did.
So within our camp we had, maybe
10 or 12, Boy Scout troops.
And so we were having
jamborees in the camp.
And our scout leaders
would write to the Scouts
in Cody and Ralston and Deaver,
and some of those other communities
that were surrounding the camp,
and they'd say, "Come on in
"and join us for our jamboree."
And they'd write back and say,
"No, no.
"We're not going in there.
"There's barbed wire around the camp,
"there're military guard towers
"with search lights and machine
gun mounts every 300 feet.
"They're POWs, we're not going in there."
And they'd write back
and say, "No, no, no.
"These are not POWs.
"These are Boy Scouts of America.
"They wear the same uniform you do.
"They read the same manual you do.
"They go after the same
merit badges you do."
Finally one of the
troops, Boy Scout Troops,
from Cody, Wyoming came in.
So we had our knot tying contests,
we had our woodworking contests,
we had those how to start a
fire without a match contests.
And after we went through all of that,
we then got paired off
with a kid from the
Boy Scout troop in Cody
to put up our tent.
So this kid and I put up our tent.
And Wyoming, it could
rain any time, any amount,
so you have to build a moat
around the tent to protect it.
So as we were digging
our moat around the tent,
the kid from the Cody troop said,
"There's a kid in my troop
in that tent below us.
"I don't really care for him.
"Would you mind if we cut the water
"to exit that way if it rains?"
(audience laughing)
(coughing)
It was really no skin off my nose.
(audience laughing)
So I said, "Sure."
And, as luck would have it,
it started raining later,
and our moat worked perfectly.
The water drained down that way,
and during the course of the evening,
tent pegs pulled and tent came down.
The kids in the tent with me
going (imitating laughing),
just laughing all night long.
And I finally said to him,
"Alan, would you please shut
up so we get some sleep?"
(audience laughing)
His name was Alan Simpson.
Sound familiar?
Became the US Senator
from Wyoming in 1978.
And the odd thing about it
is that through junior high school,
high school, and college,
we wrote to each other.
And then in '74 I got
elected to the House,
and he got elected to the Senate '78.
And even as conservative
and Republican he was,
as liberal and Democrat as I was,
we were the best of friends.
And we are still to today.
Let's go to 9/11.
I'm Secretary of Transportation,
and I'm having breakfast that morning
with the Deputy Prime Minister of Belgium,
who also serves as the
Minister of Transport,
and with Jane Garvey,
who was head of the FAA.
And the three of us were having breakfast,
talking about aviation issues
before the European Union.
And my Chief of Staff came in and said,
"Secretary, may I see you?"
So I excused myself and
went into my office.
And as I went into my office,
at the other end is a TV console.
There were the twin towers,
black smoke billowing out of one of them.
I said, "John, what's that?"
He said, "We don't know.
"We've heard the possibility
of general aviation,
"aircraft, commercial aircraft,
"and even the possibility
"of an explosion within the building."
So I watch the TV for a little while,
and then said, "I've got
to go into the meeting."
So I went back in and explained to Ann,
I mean to Jane, and to Mrs.
Durant what I had just seen.
And six, seven minutes
later John came back in,
"May I see you?"
So I excused myself,
went back into my office.
He said, "It's been confirmed
it was a commercial airliner
"that went into the building."
So as I was coming up
to the TV looking at it,
all of a sudden I see this gray object
going across the screen.
And then on the left side
of the screen it disappears,
and this white, yellow,
orangey, billowy cloud
appears on the left side of the screen.
And I go, "Holy cow, what was that?"
Or words to that effect.
(audience chuckling)
And so then I really started to listen
and look at the TV screen.
So after about seven, eight
minutes of this I said,
"John, I've gotta go back in,
"get myself out of this
breakfast meeting."
So I went in, I explained to
Jane Garvey and Mrs. Durant
what I had just seen
on the television set,
and I said, "I don't know
what's going on up in New York,
"but it's something I'm
gonna have to deal with.
"Jane, you've gotta get back
to the FAA operation center."
And so by the time I
got back into my office,
the White House called and said,
"Get over here right away."
So I grab some papers and
threw them in my briefcase,
and went downstairs to the car.
And as we're going in West Executive Drive
at the White House,
people are running out of the
executive office building.
They're running out of the White House.
And I said to my driver and security guy,
"Is there something
wrong with this picture?
"We're driving in and everybody
else is running away."
So get out of the car,
went into the White House.
And the guard said,
"You have to be briefed by Mr. Clarke
"in the Situation Room."
So I went into the Situation Room,
and Dick briefed me.
And he really didn't tell me much more
than what I already had
heard on television.
And then he said,
"You've gotta be in the PEOC."
I said, "The PEOC?
"What's the PEOC?"
P-E-O-C.
Presidential Emergency Operation Center.
And I said, "I have no
idea where that is."
And there was a secret
service agent standing there.
So he said, "I'll take you down."
Now, this is a bunker that's
way under the White House.
And it's supposed to be
nuclear bomb proof I guess.
But in any event, I went down there,
and the Vice President
was already down there.
And there's a table,
probably about 30, 40 feet long,
about 15 feet wide,
with chairs all the way around.
And between each of the
chairs are telephones.
So I took one set of phone, one phone,
and set it up to my office
at the Department of Transportation,
and the other one to the FAA,
and sat there in the PEOC
for the rest of the day.
A military aide came in,
to the Vice President who
was sitting across from me,
said, "There's a plane coming towards DC."
So I said to Monte Belger,
the number two at FAA,
I said, "Monte, I
understand there's a plane
"coming towards DC.
"Do you know where it is
and what's the plane?"
Said, "Well, we've been
tracking this plane,
"but the transponder's been turned off.
"So all we're doing is watching
the white little target
"on every 11 second swing of the radar."
So, now I said, "Looking at radar,
"can you relate it to
where it's on the ground?"
Which is difficult to do.
He said, "No, it's somewhere
in the middle of Pennsylvania."
So every so often I'd be asking,
"Where's the plane?"
And so he would sorta guess
as to where he thought the plane was.
Well, on my credenza behind my desk,
I had a monitor outline of the 48 States,
Hawaii, and Alaska.
Just peppered with dots.
Well, if I took my mouse
and put it on a dot,
all of a sudden there'd be
a flag that would come up,
and it would say UA123 (coughing).
United Airlines flight 123.
And then it would say PDX
and a number of navigational
points, and then ORD.
So I knew it left Portland,
this is the route it's gonna be flying,
lands at O'Hare field in Chicago.
And then the next line, it would say B752.
Bowing 757, 200 series.
Then it would give me the
compass direction of the plane,
speed, tell me about how much
fuel (coughing) in the plane,
tell me a lot about the airplane.
And that was the transponder
that was turned off.
So every so often I'd ask, "Where is it?"
He said, "Well, I think
it's north of Baltimore."
"Where is it now?"
(coughing)
"Probably near the
Great Falls (mumbling)."
(coughing)
"Where's it now?"
"Oh, probably near Pentagon City
"going towards National Airport."
"Where is it now?"
"Oops."
"Oops?
"Oops what?"
"We just lost the target.
"We just lost the bogie."
"Where'd you lose it?"
"Somewhere between Pentagon
City National Airport."
(coughing)
And then about that time,
someone broke into the phones and said,
"Secretary, we just got a call
"from an Arlington County Officer
"who saw an American Airlines
go into the Pentagon."
Well, Al-Queda used to always
talk about three icons.
Military icon, political
icon, economic icon.
And, obviously, that day
they hit the economic icon
the World Trade Center.
And then they hit the
military icon, the Pentagon.
And I said to Monte, I said,
"Monte, when you see
one of something happen,
"especially when you see
three commercial airliners
"being used as missiles."
And I said, "Once you
see one of something,
"it's an accident.
"But if you see a second
of the same thing,
"it's a pattern or a trend.
"But when you see three of the same thing
"in a relatively short period,
"it's a plan or an action."
And I said, "In the military,
"they have something called a stand down.
"And we've gotta do our own stand down.
"Gotta bring all the planes down."
And he said, "We'll
bring all the planes down
"per pilot discretion."
And I said, "Monte,
screw pilot discretion.
"I want all the planes down."
'Cause I didn't want someone
over Albuquerque or Phoenix
go flying into Los Angeles.
I wanted those planes
down as soon as possible.
And at that point, we had
5,368 airplanes in the air.
And in two hours and 20
minutes we had them all down,
on the ground, safely,
and without incident.
And that morning, I also
pulled three people out of ACS,
Aviation Civil Security of the FAA.
Started having them work
on a new security regimen.
Because Tuesday afternoon,
the CEOs of the airlines
were calling up, saying,
"When are we gonna be able to fly."
And I said to them,
"You're not gonna be able to fly
"until we establish a
new security regimen."
So, as the folks were working
on that security regimen,
on Thursday there was a Cabinet meeting
of the Cabinet with the member
of the House and Senate,
Democratic and Republican leadership.
And towards the end of that meeting,
Congressman David Bonner,
from Detroit, Michigan, said,
"Mr. President.
"We have a very large
Arab-American population,
"living in Michigan.
"And they're very concerned
"about all the rhetoric they're hearing
"about banning Middle
Easterners from flying,
"keeping Muslims off airplanes."
One and on and on.
And the President said,
"David, you're absolutely right.
"We are equally concerned
about all that rhetoric,
"and we don't wanna have happen today
"what happened to Norm in 1942."
And so when I got back from the meeting,
and asked how our security
regimen was coming along,
they said the first one,
right at the top, was,
no racial or ethnic profiling.
And so, we were able to,
found out the rest of it,
by late Friday afternoon,
and issue that in the
form of a regulation.
But again, it was a time in which
there was a great deal of concern,
about security, and about how to deal
with an ethnic or racial minority,
and, including, a religious group.
And then towards the end
of September, in Arizona,
there was a shooting
and killing of a person
who owned a gas station and a mini mart.
And when the apprehended
the killer, they asked him,
why did you shoot and kill this guy?
He said, simply, "Because
he looked like the enemy."
This fellow happened to be a Sikh,
with his head gear and
facial hair, leg bindings.
And other than a simple explanation,
'cause he looked like the enemy.
On Monday the, I guess that'd
be the 17th of September,
President gathered a large number
of Arab-Americans and Muslims
at the Islamic Studies
Center in Washington, DC.
And he said,
"We know who did that last Tuesday.
"They were not loyal Arab-Americans.
"They were not faithful
followers of Islam.
"They were terrorists,
"and we're gonna go after them."
Similarly, with the killing of this Sikh.
He had a very large group of
South Asian Indian Americans
come to the White House in October,
and he told them that
we are not gonna allow
this kind of hate crime to occur,
and we will pursue
whoever does these things,
until they're brought to justice.
So all of this, again,
sort of relates to this December
7th, in terms of security
and the need for weighing civil liberties,
then 9/11, then now, today,
with ISIS or ISIL.
And all of us have to be very vigilant
in the protection of our
constitutional rights.
We don't have to be vigilantes about it,
but we have to be very vigilant
about our constitutional rights.
And at the same time,
I know there's a security concern
that has to be attended to.
I think in a democratic society of ours,
that's something that
all of us are able to do,
in an open and free discussion.
But it's something that bothers me,
because in this discussion
of the political presidential
election run up to 2016,
some things are being said
that really bother me,
and sort of make me think
back to December 7, 1941,
or 9/11/2001,
or the present circumstance,
including I-S-I-S and I-S-I-L.
So it's something that all
of us have to deal with.
And to the young people in the audience,
I want you to pursue your
career and professional goals.
But as you do so,
think about taking some
time to offer yourself
as a subject matter expert
to your Mayor, your county executive,
Governor, or President.
Because, as you pursue
your professional goal,
I want you to also think
about what you can do
to lend your subject matter
expertise to public policy,
and help in that way.
Not everybody has to run for office.
In a democratic society,
you have everyone from a well-read citizen
to the person who runs for office.
But the one who runs for office
may be one or two percent
of the population.
So you may not be in that
group that wants to run,
but you want to do
something public service.
And that's where you can still
pursue your own career goal,
and you volunteer to be a member
of a Board or a commission
to whatever level of government
that you would like to lend yourself to.
So with that, let me stop,
and maybe take some
questions and answers, Mary,
if that's all right?
Okay?
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
- So, I think this is on, yes this is on.
So now, we are going to open it up
for questions and answers.
I believe when you all walked in
you should have received a card,
so please do write down
questions that you have
for Secretary Mineta.
And we do have aides
who should be coming
up and down the aisles
to collect your questions.
So while that's happening,
I do have a couple of quick
questions to start us off.
Okay.
The first one is,
I was very struck by
the story that you told,
and especially in terms
of the aftermath of 9/11,
and the response by
President Bush at the time,
saying absolutely no
racial or ethnic profiling,
is just as important as the
security of the American people.
So I wanted to hear a little bit more
about how that sentiment
and that goal and vision
was also part of the creation of the TSA
under your leadership?
- Next question (coughing)?
(Mary laughing)
(audience laughing)
Well, right after we had come into office,
President Bush had invited
my wife and me to Camp David.
And so after dinner one night,
we had just sort of a
talk around the table,
and I did explain, or talk about,
'cause he did ask,
"Well, tell me about the
evacuation and internment."
We spent quite a bit of time
about the evacuation and internment.
And this would have been in,
probably about March of 2001.
And so, the whole idea
of grounding the planes,
really, I suppose if I
had to think about it,
I don't know what I
would have done on 9/11,
but I knew I was comfortable
in having to order all the planes down.
Now, the formation
of the Transportation
Security Administration
came because in the old system,
the airlines were in charge
of the inspection of
passengers onto airplanes.
And they would contract
with independent companies
to do this at all their airports.
And, of course, those are
always done on the lowest bid,
and given to the cheapest
contractor that submitted a bid.
And so, obviously, 9/11 said to us
there were a lot of flaws in the system.
So we put together our own legislation,
and the center of it was
that these inspectors
were going to be government employees.
And that became a very major arm wrestle
between our department and the Congress
as we're having
the Transportation
Security Administration Act
make its way through the House and Senate.
'Cause many wanted to just keep going
with private contractors.
But I felt that in order
to have the same standard,
whether you were in New
York or Resume Speed, Iowa,
or wherever,
to that it had to really
be a government employee,
and we prevailed on that count.
Now, we did include a provision
in that original bill,
that allowed up to five communities
to have outside contractors do the work.
And we based it on large HUB carrier,
small non-point carrier,
and we had various varieties.
But we did allow five airports
to have non-government contract employees.
But they have to have the same system
as all the other government owned,
or government operated security systems.
Does that answer that Mary?
- [Mary] So we have a lot of questions.
And I do apologize if
we don't actually get
to your question,
I'm gonna do the best I can.
One question is,
can you talk about serving as a Democrat
in a Republican administration's Cabinet.
Considering the political
divisiveness in the country today,
what advice might you have to offer,
while we're on the partisan divides?
- Well (throat clearing).
This is really a difficult question
because today it is,
the way things operate in DC,
totally different from what they were,
even as recently as 15 years ago.
Today...
Well, let me go back to
when I was in the Congress.
Tip O'Neill required us
to be there at 12 noon
on Monday for the first vote,
and then stay until the
last vote on Friday at 3pm.
Today, the first vote
is on Tuesday at 6:30,
so members come in late Tuesday afternoon,
for a vote on, for their
6:30 vote on Tuesday.
Then they're there on Wednesday.
And the last vote is at
three o'clock on Thursday,
if they have a vote.
Now, in probably 90% of the days,
or 90% of Thursdays, they
haven't had votes on Thursday.
So they all leave early Thursday morning
to go home to their home districts.
They don't know each other,
they don't know even the subject matter
of the committees they're assigned to.
And I still deal with many of the members,
and it's appalling to me
that they don't know the subject matter
of the committees they're assigned to.
On the other hand,
running campaigns is so
much more expensive today
than it was some time back.
So they're all dialing
for dollars all the time.
Now, in my first race in 1974,
between the primary and
the general election,
I spent $247,000.
In my last race in 1994,
I raised $1.3 million,
spent $700,000.
Today, there isn't a race
that is under $2-2.5 million.
And so they're having to
raise that money all the time.
But what's even worse is the
fact that they're not in DC,
they're not dealing with
their subject matters,
they don't know each other.
We used to have fights in sub-committee,
full committee, on the floor,
you'd slap each other on the back,
say, "C'mon let's go have dinner,
"let's go have a drink."
And that doesn't occur today.
There may be some isolated
examples of that happening.
And so it makes it very difficult.
And on top of that,
the members themselves are
much more polarized today,
and I think that part of it is,
if you don't know somebody,
you tend to be a little harsher on them.
And I think that's what happens,
is what's happening today.
And there isn't that personal
relationship that existed.
And as conservative as Alan Simpson was,
and as liberal as I was,
we'd still be able to have dinner,
talk to each other about issues going on.
And that really doesn't happen today.
Now, there's a group of
bipartisan members of Congress,
or former members,
who are trying to work on
trying to get this corrected
right now.
- [Mary] I think of a, sort of,
a follow up question almost.
Not exactly.
But what was the most
significant difference
between President Clinton and
President Bush (giggling).
I'm not sure you can really answer that,
but I can't resist to ask.
(audience laughing)
I do say, I do have a real card here.
- Well.
President Bush was a CEO-type of person,
where we, as Cabinet members.
I remember when I spoke to him on,
what was that, January 2nd I guess it was,
when we went down to Austin to
meet him for the first time.
And I had three things in mind.
I wanna talk to him about
budget, policy, and personnel.
So when I talked about budget he says,
"No, no no."
He says, "You're gonna have to arm wrestle
"with everybody else at OMB
for your budget requirements."
Then he said, on policy and personnel,
"I'm bringing you on as
a subject matter expert.
"So I want you to give to me
what you're policy advice is,
"but I just don't you
want hiring only Democrats
"at the Department of Transportation."
And I said, "No, no.
"I'll be using the
Presidential Personnel Office
"to recruit and bring people in."
So the President really was a delegator.
He expected me to do my job.
He wasn't overseeing what
I was doing or saying.
Although we had to clear the speeches.
But there was very little rewritten.
President Clinton...
Oh, and then Cabinet meetings.
We were to have Cabinet
meetings every month.
And if it was announced
to start at 10 o'clock,
you knew right at the top of the hour,
the meeting was going to start.
And there was always an agenda,
and it would always fall
under a certain pattern.
Now, in the case of President Clinton,
I came in as Secretary of
Commerce in June of 2000.
Bill Daley was the Secretary of Commerce;
he was leaving to go
run the Gore campaign.
And I was Senior Vice
President at Lockheed Martin.
Six o'clock, I had packed up my briefcase,
I was about to leave,
and the phone rang.
Should I answer that phone, or let it go?
Should I answer that phone,
(audience laughing)
or let it go?
So I finally picked up the phone.
It was John Podesta,
the Chief of Staff for
President Clinton calling.
He says, "Norm," he says.
"Bill Daley's leaving Commerce.
"The boss has given me
a short list of names
"to find out if these
people would be interested
"in becoming Secretary of Commerce.
"Would you be interested?"
And I said, "John,
"you want me to crawl through
the telephone wire right now
"to your office,
(audience laughing)
"to give you my answer?"
Oh, he said, "Okay, okay,
I'll put you down for yes."
(audience laughing)
And then on Thursday morning,
President Clinton called up,
he says, "Norm, I'm sending your name
"up to the Senate this morning,
"nominating you for
Secretary of Commerce."
So those were the two interviews,
two phone interviews I had (coughing)
for Secretary of Commerce.
Within about a week to 10 days (coughing),
I had been confirmed by the Senate.
Now, they had a Cabinet meeting in June,
but the one before that was March.
And so, and then we had one in July.
And it was supposed to start at 10.
President didn't come
in until about 10:45,
and it went until about 12:30.
With President Bush, you
knew it was gonna start
at a certain time,
and it would last one hour.
We had only two meetings
that went beyond one hour.
On the 13th of September after 9/11,
and then in April of '05,
when they were talking about
the ramp up in the Middle East.
And so, that meeting went over an hour.
And there was a televised,
closed circuit program
with our US Ambassador in Afghanistan,
and with the commanding general,
I can't recall his name,
who was in Qatar.
So we had a three-way Cabinet meeting,
Cabinet room, Kabul, and Qatar.
And that one went over an hour.
The only time we had meeting over an hour.
But in the case of President Clinton,
it would be a freewheeling conversation,
and it could go on for
(Mary laughing)
an hour and a half.
And so, but there were just
two different approaches,
and I really felt that the Cabinet meeting
under President Bush,
was a vehicle for him to
have a press conference.
'Cause we would not...
If you were the Secretary of Defense
and you brought something up,
all of us around the table
would not offer suggestions
or advice or anything.
And so, it was a vastly
different approach.
- [Mary] I do have a few questions
as follow up to your stories
about the internment camp experience,
so I'm gonna ask a few of these.
First one is,
how has your experience as
an interned Japanese-American
informed your political
views and career in politics?
- It has, in terms of my own
service as a city councilman,
as Mayor, as a member of Congress,
one of the things I've
always kept in sight,
was to be able to speak for
those who are not represented,
or who are underrepresented.
And so, I always felt
that there were groups
that were always not represented
in the actions of the government.
And so when the whole idea of the ADA,
the Americans with
Disabilities Act came up,
with the National Council on Disabilities,
I wrote the whole transportation
portion of the ADA.
But, having been interned,
doesn't become the driving wedge,
but is the backstop that keeps pushing me
in terms of making sure that people's,
that their issues, are not disregarded,
or not dealt with.
And so, when I became Mayor,
just as I had been appointed
to the city council in 1967,
the Asian-American population
in San Jose at that time
was probably 2.5, 3%.
The Hispanic population was about 18%.
So when I became Mayor,
I left a vacancy on the city council.
So I said to the Hispanic community,
"Get together and come up with some names
"for me to consider,
"to be appointed to the city council."
And so I was able to appoint
the first Mexican-American
to the city council in San Jose.
But I've always tried to,
not use the evacuation and
internment as the driving wedge,
but as a backstop to really
make sure I did my job.
- [Mary] Another question was,
what was the attitude of
your friends in the camp
towards serving in the US Military?
And I think there's another question
that another audience member
asked which is quite similar.
Just, in particular,
asking about the responses
of your older brother,
to the loyalty questionnaire
that was issued
in camp years.
- Okay.
The loyalty questionnaire was something
that was given to all the draft-age males,
and the (throat clearing),
there were a number of questions,
and it came down to, I think
it was question #27 was,
would you forswear allegiance
to the Emperor of Japan,
and swear allegiance to the
United States of America.
And there were a lot of people who said,
"I've never sworn allegiance
to the Emperor of Japan,
"so why should I have to sign a document
"that says I'm gonna
forswear my allegiance
"to the Emperor of Japan."
And then question 28 was,
would you serve in the
military forces, armed forces,
of the United States?
And a lot of them says,
having evacuated and interned
me from my own home State,
no, I'm not gonna serve.
So many people answered
no on 27 and no on 28,
and they became known as the no-no boys.
And there were, I believe,
something like 63 from
Heart Mountain, Wyoming,
who were convicted of
violating federal law,
and served, maybe, at
least, I'd be guessing,
about some two to three years
at McNeil Island in Washington,
the State of Washington.
And so there was that
loyalty questionnaire
that was circulated to
the people, the males,
and that created a stir
within the community,
because of the 4C draft classification.
And they lifted that in the Spring of,
or the latter part, of 1943.
And as a result of that,
the full 42nd regimented
combat team was formed,
which was an all
Japanese-American military unit
serving in Europe.
And when they asked for volunteers,
and I believe they were
looking for some 4,000,
they had something like 7,000 volunteers
from the camps to the Army.
And I used to always wonder whether or not
the food in the camp was that much worse
than what they might
experience in the Army.
But in any event,
and the full 42nd ended up, and still is,
the most highly decorated unit
in US Army Military history.
And for a regimental combat team,
which is roughly 4,000
people, they had, I believe,
23 medals of honor that were
awarded during World War II
to them.
So, in fact, President Truman,
in receiving the full 42nd
back to the United States
after World War II,
had a parade of the full 42nd.
And as he put on the
Presidential Unit Citation
on their flag,
he mentioned that the soldiers
had beaten two enemies:
one in the field, and the
other, prejudice at home.
And I credit the full
42nd and their action,
that enabled a lot of us
to be able to pursue public service,
because of their record in the military.
- [Mary] So another follow
up question to that is,
did you harbor resentment
toward the US government at all
for interning you and your family?
If so, how did you overcome that
to eventually serve at the
level of public service
that you did?
- Well, I think the amazing
thing about (throat clearing)
about this whole story,
is that 120,000 people went
through this experience,
and didn't come out with
rancor or bitterness.
Sure, there are some who
harbored rancor and bitterness.
But I think the more clary and calm,
was that most people said,
"This should never, ever
happen to anyone else again."
And I think by and large,
the Japanese-American community
has been very, very strong
about making sure that something like this
never ever happens again.
I never (throat clearing)
went through any kind of
feeling of bitterness or
remorse about what happened,
and I don't think most people
who had experienced the
internment and evacuation did so,
but they came out with
a very strong feeling
that something like this should
never, ever happen again.
And that's why I worked on,
with a lot of people, the HR442,
which was the Civil Liberties Act of 1982,
that was signed into
law by President Reagan.
And this called for an
apology by the Congress
to the Japanese-American population,
and a redress amount that was awarded
to those that experience redress,
or, evacuation and internment.
(throat clearing)
- [Mary] Along those lines,
in terms of the current-day
political situation,
as we've seen in the media today,
there're constant references
towards Japanese-American internment
as a way of dealing with
the current refugee crisis.
What can you say more about
your response to that?
- First of all,
there should be a very strong response
to anyone who tries to use
an Executive Order 9066,
or the experience of the
internment of Japanese-Americans
to apply to anyone today.
To me, I just don't understand
how someone could be calling
for the deportation of
all illegal immigrants
and their families,
when their families are American citizens.
I mean, the children of these
people who have immigrated,
I don't know how they just
summarily deport them.
They're US citizens,
and that ought not to
be part of the picture.
And so, now, I feel very strongly
that people should not be using
the evacuation and internment
as a way of taking care
of the illegals right now.
They've already interned
women and children
who have come across the border,
and again, I just don't think
that's the way to solve the problem.
(audience applauding)
- [Mary] So I think we have
time for one last question,
and this is an appropriate one.
I think I actually got through the stack!
So in your experience,
what are the three most
essential traits of leadership,
being a leader?
- Well, the first one is something that,
there're two things that all of us own,
and we should not give that up in any way.
One is our name.
And the second is our integrity.
And no matter what the
circumstance might be,
we ought not to compromise
our own principles and ideals
just for some short term gain,
(scattered applauding)
or even long term gain.
To me, the whole name of
the game is integrity,
and it just makes me sick
when I hear about people
who couch their answers
to whatever the question might be.
But the other thing that just, to me,
there is so much,
well, I don't know necessarily corruption,
but there is just too much
people not standing by
their own principles.
And so, in a way,
I'd say one is integrity,
two is integrity,
three is integrity.
(audience laughing)
But there are leadership
traits that people,
I think, should have.
And today, when I hear people saying,
"Well, I'm not a politician."
Well then why are you
running for public office?
(audience laughing)
You wouldn't go to a
brain surgeon who says,
"I'm really not a brain surgeon,
"I just practice every day at it."
(audience laughing)
And to me,
regardless of what profession
or background we are in,
we wanna deal with subject matter experts.
People who know what
they're talking about.
People who devote their time to the study
of what it is they're doing.
And I just don't see that
in a lot of instances today.
So, in any event,
the integrity's still, no
matter how I look at it,
is still number one.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
- Thank you.
Wonderful, thank you.
- Thank you very much everybody.
- Thank you all so much for coming, and,
well, this was wonderful.
And I can't thank you
enough for taking time out
to come see us.
You have no idea how busy his schedule is,
even though he's retired
from public service.
(audience laughing)
- Thank you very much everyone.
- Okay.